-En cinq mandats,
il a navigué dans cinq groupes
politiques différents,
sans pour autant renier
ses valeurs.
Mon invité est engagé au centre
depuis presque 50 ans.
Un centriste un peu rebelle,
voire insoumis, vous allez voir.
Générique
...
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Dans les années 70,
un lycéen qui s'intéressait un peu
à la politique
était encore souvent attiré
par une figure
comme Che Guevara.
Vous, votre Che Guevara,
il avait pas les cheveux longs,
il était chauve,
il parlait avec un phrasé
un peu ampoulé :
c'était Valéry Giscard d'Estaing.
Pour lui, vous étiez prêt à tout,
jusqu'à vous faire exclure du lycée.
Racontez-nous.
-Oui, je me suis engagé,
j'avais 16 ans,
j'étais au lycée.
J'étais d'ailleurs dans un lycée
entouré par beaucoup de gens
de gauche.
J'étais pourtant venu
d'un milieu modeste,
j'étais le seul giscardo-giscardien.
J'ai fait la campagne
du président,
du candidat Giscard d'Estaing,
en 1974.
J'étais un peu seul,
au lycée, mais je l'ai fait,
et je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui,
je ne le regrette absolument pas.
-Vous vous êtes fait exclure
du lycée...
-De l'internat, car j'avais imité
la signature de ma grand-mère
pour m'autoriser à sortir
pour aller assister à un meeting
du candidat Giscard d'Estaing,
à Nantes.
Evidemment, comme je suis
un mauvais imitateur,
en tous les cas, en écriture,
je me suis fait choper
et j'ai été viré de l'internat.
-Vous êtes passionné
de Giscard pour ses idées,
ses valeurs.
Vous avez présidé l'antenne locale
des jeunes giscardiens
à Saint-Nazaire.
C'est une ville profondément
ancrée à gauche.
-Depuis l'éternité.
-Dans la figure de Giscard,
qu'est-ce qui a pu susciter
un tel enthousiasme
chez le jeune homme de 16 ans ?
18 ans sur la photo
mais 16 ans au moment
de la campagne présidentielle.
-D'abord, parce que Giscard,
c'était la modernité.
On sortait des années de Gaulle,
Pompidou.
Pour moi,
Giscard a fait passer
la 5e République
du noir et blanc à la couleur.
C'était le seul candidat
qui s'adressait à la jeunesse,
avec des idées modernes...
-Le droit de vote
à 18 ans.
-...avec des projets de réformes
qu'il a réalisées.
C'est pas uniquement un programme
et on passe à autre chose.
Il a réalisé son projet,
des réformes,
comme l'abaissement
de la majorité de 21 à 18 ans,
entre autres,
mais aussi l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse, le divorce
par consentement mutuel,
beaucoup de réformes
de société qui, aujourd'hui encore,
marquent notre pays.
-La passion Giscard
ne s'est pas éteinte avec le temps.
On vous a vu le recevoir
dans votre circonscription,
c'était en 2016,
pour célébrer les 40 ans
de son élection
à la présidence de la République.
-Oui.
-Vous avez même racheté
sa dernière voiture,
c'était une Smart.
Vous avez fait
votre campagne législative
dans la Smart de Giscard d'Estaing.
Quand on voit ça,
ça va au-delà
de la politique,
vous êtes un pur fan.
-Oui, c'est important
d'avoir des repères
quand on fait de la politique.
Je trouvais que c'était,
là aussi,
une marque d'affection
et d'attachement
au président Giscard d'Estaing,
que de racheter sa dernière voiture.
-Giscard est à l'origine
de votre engagement au centre,
mais François Léotard
vous a mis le pied à l'étrier.
-Oui.
En tous les cas, ma collaboration
avec François Léotard
comme assistant parlementaire,
et aussi à son cabinet
lorsqu'il était ministre,
ça a été pour moi le vrai démarrage
de ma vie politique,
parce que je faisais
de la politique en province,
et là, j'arrivais à Paris,
comme Rastignac.
J'allais dire : "A nous deux, Paris.
A nous deux, la politique."
Je dois beaucoup à François Léotard
parce qu'il m'a appris énormément
de choses.
J'ai beaucoup d'affection
pour François Léotard.
-Vous êtes attaché
aux valeurs centristes
mais moins attaché aux partis
ou aux groupes politiques
de l'Assemblée.
Depuis votre 1re élection, en 2002,
vous avez appartenu
aux groupes UMP, UDI, MoDem,
Libertés et Territoires,
à nouveau UDI,
Horizons,
le parti d'Edouard Philippe.
Vous avez la bougeotte ?
-Non, pas du tout.
Mes valeurs
sont toujours les mêmes :
libéral, social,
européen, humaniste.
Maintenant, les partis politiques,
eux, ils ont beaucoup changé,
en 30 ou 40 ans.
Ils ont changé d'alliances,
ils ont changé de nom.
-Vous, vous avez pas changé.
-Moi, j'ai pas changé.
Les groupes parlementaires
sont des outils
pour travailler
à l'Assemblée nationale,
mais ce ne sont pas forcément
des ancrages de convictions.
Mes convictions sont les mêmes :
je suis resté au centre-droit,
je ne varierai pas de cet ancrage.
-En basculant
dans la majorité
présidentielle
sur la dernière législative.
-Oui, parce que je me disais
qu'en 2022, entre Marine Le Pen
et Emmanuel Macron, pour moi,
il n'y avait pas d'option possible.
C'était Emmanuel Macron.
Je suis
dans la majorité présidentielle,
je suis loyal,
mais je suis libre.
-J'allais parler de votre compte
Twitter,
où vous affichez ce qui ressemble
à une devise, justement :
"Loyal mais libre."
Je me mets dans la tête
d'un président de groupe
à l'Assemblée,
en voyant ça, il doit se dire :
"Yannick Favennec,
"loyal mais libre,
il ne doit pas être fiable."
-Je ne dois de comptes
qu'à mes électeurs.
Je ne dois de comptes
qu'à celles et ceux qui,
depuis presque 25 ans,
cinq mandats,
dont le dernier,
j'étais le seul député
de la majorité
élu ou réélu dès le 1er tour.
Je ne dois des comptes
qu'à ceux qui m'ont fait confiance.
-Pensez aux présidents de groupe.
-Tant pis.
-"Quand il y aura une tempête,
inutile de compter sur lui."
-Quand il y a la tempête,
je suis fidèle à mes convictions,
tout simplement.
-Je pense
à la réforme des retraites.
Au Figaro,
vous dites que vous voterez
contre la réforme des retraites.
-Je n'ai jamais dévié
de mes convictions.
Ma campagne législative,
je l'ai faite en partie
sur la nécessité de faire
une réforme des retraites,
non pas en faisant de l'âge
le totem de la réforme,
mais en prenant en compte
le nombre de trimestres cotisés,
et je n'ai pas changé
par rapport à ça.
Je suis resté fidèle
à mes convictions.
-On vous l'a fait payer,
ça, en interne ?
-Joker.
-Le silence...
-Oui, on me l'a fait payer,
bien sûr.
On me le fait encore payer
aujourd'hui.
Peu importe, je reste fidèle
à mes convictions.
-On vous l'a fait payer.
Visiblement,
vos électeurs, eux, non.
Vous l'avez dit,
vous avez été réélu
cinq fois d'affilée,
trois fois, sur vos cinq victoires,
élu au 1er tour.
Vous dites que vous ne devez
votre élection
qu'à vos électeurs.
Est-ce que c'est pas prétentieux ?
-J'ai été élu parce que
mes électeurs m'ont fait confiance.
-Oui mais vous avez une investiture,
le soutien d'un parti.
-Sincèrement,
je suis élu ou réélu sur mon nom,
sur ce que je défends.
-Et sur votre ancrage territorial.
-C'est mon ancrage territorial,
absolument.
C'est le fait
que je suis sur le terrain
du lundi matin au dimanche soir.
Bien sûr, le mardi, le mercredi
et le jeudi, qui est réservé
au travail ici, à l'Assemblée,
mais je suis en permanence
présent sur le terrain.
C'est ça aussi, je crois,
que les électeurs me reconnaissent.
-On va revoir un extrait
d'un reportage,
tourné par Maïté Frémont,
qui vous avait suivi sur le terrain,
dans ce combat que vous menez
pour votre territoire et la Mayenne,
qui est très concerné
par la problématique...
-Pour 87 %
du territoire national
qui est un désert médical.
-...des déserts médicaux.
-Bonjour,
je suis Guillaume Garot,
député de la 1re circonscription
de la Mayenne.
-Bonjour. Yannick Favennec,
député de la 3e circonscription
de la Mayenne.
-Ensemble, nous nous battons...
-Contre les déserts médicaux.
-A TOUT DE SUITE.
-J'ai choisi cet extrait,
c'est le début du reportage,
que vous pouvez voir
sur YouTube,
car Guillaume Garot
n'est pas de votre bord politique.
Il est député socialiste.
-Oui.
-Vous partagez ce même combat
pour votre territoire.
Quand on défend
son territoire,
la notion de droite,
de gauche,
ça a plus lieu d'être ?
-L'accès aux soins,
c'est l'intérêt général.
Première chose.
Les réponses
sont dans l'intérêt général.
Je vais vous dire une chose.
Les Français
n'ont pas donné de majorité absolue
au président de la République.
Ils ont dit : "Débrouillez-vous.
Apprenez à travailler ensemble,
"à coconstruire ensemble,
parlez-vous enfin."
Avec Guillaume Garot,
c'est ce que l'on fait
dans notre département
de la Mayenne.
Les Mayennais apprécient
notre collaboration,
car ils savent qu'on a un objectif,
c'est de faire en sorte
que l'accès aux soins
se fasse de façon plus égale
sur le territoire national,
notamment en Mayenne,
qui est un des trois départements
de France les plus impactés
par cette difficulté
d'avoir un médecin.
-Avant le quiz,
revenons sur un épisode
de votre vie politique
qui vous a blessé.
Votre femme a été
une de vos collaboratrices
parlementaires à l'Assemblée.
-Je suis fier qu'elle l'ait été,
car elle travaillait.
Les Mayennais s'en souviennent.
-Vous avez dû la licencier
à la suite
de l'affaire Fillon,
pour respecter la loi
sur la moralisation
de la vie publique.
Vous dites que cette loi
est une mauvaise loi,
ou que c'est le prix à payer
pour éviter les abus réels ?
-Je pense qu'effectivement,
beaucoup...
Parce qu'elle était pas la seule,
mon épouse,
à être engagée par son mari,
en tous les cas,
travaillant avec un parent.
Je pense qu'on a payé
pour ce qu'une minorité
a fait ou n'a pas fait, justement.
Mon épouse,
elle a des compétences.
Je suis très fier
qu'elle ait collaboré avec moi.
Je regrette qu'effectivement,
pour une minorité
qui a mal agi,
une majorité qui travaillait
se retrouve pénalisée
ou s'est retrouvée pénalisée
il y a six ans de ça.
-On passe à notre quiz,
à présent.
Je rappelle le principe :
je vais commencer des phrases
et vous allez devoir les compléter.
On y va.
Si Giscard avait présidé la France
aujourd'hui...
-La France irait certainement
beaucoup mieux.
D'abord, les réformes
auraient été faites.
-Ca, c'est un coup porté
à Emmanuel Macron ?
-Aujourd'hui, on est incapables
de réformer ce pays.
Ce n'est pas de la faute
du président de la République.
Le peuple français a changé,
mais oui, je crois que la France
serait entrée encore plus fortement
dans la modernité,
dans le 21e siècle,
et que les réformes
auraient été faites.
-Après plus de 20 ans
à l'Assemblée,
je me dis parfois...
-Je me dis parfois
que ça beaucoup changé.
-Qu'est-ce qui a le plus changé ?
-Je pense qu'on est passé
dans un autre mode
de fonctionnement.
D'abord, il y a pas de respect,
il y a plus certaines valeurs
qui existaient
il y a un peu plus de 20 ans,
quand j'ai été élu pour la 1re fois.
Je le regrette car c'est important
d'avoir une Assemblée nationale
qui fonctionne
dans de meilleures conditions
que c'est le cas aujourd'hui.
-Ma plus grande satisfaction
en tant que député...
-Ma plus grande satisfaction,
c'est...
Il y a tellement de choses
que je pourrais vous dire.
Par exemple,
cette semaine est entrée en vigueur
une proposition de loi
pour laquelle je me suis
beaucoup battu avec d'autres,
c'est la déconjugalisation
de l'allocation adulte handicapé,
très importante, très attendue
par les personnes concernées.
Ca montre qu'on peut agir
concrètement,
quand on fait de la politique,
pour le quotidien
et pour le bien des gens.
-Une dernière question.
En plus de 20 ans à l'Assemblée,
vous n'avez pas réussi
à faire adopter une seule
proposition de loi
à votre nom.
Est-ce que c'est pas le prix
de votre liberté,
de votre indépendance revendiquée ?
-D'abord, je vous parlais
de l'allocation adulte handicapé,
j'y ai beaucoup contribué,
avec d'autres,
et puis laisser sa trace
sur une proposition de loi,
c'est pas forcément un but en soi.
On peut faire avancer les choses
par les amendements,
qu'on peut faire adopter,
Dieu merci,
et puis il y a tellement de lois
dans notre pays
que finalement, avoir une loi
au nom de Favennec-Bécot,
c'est pas mon objectif numéro un.
Mon objectif numéro un,
c'est d'être vraiment au plus près
des préoccupations
de mes concitoyens.
-Merci beaucoup d'être venu.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA